>> Laura: THIS IS GOING TO
SHOCK YOU TO THINK THIS IS
HAPPENING UNDER THE WATCH OF ONE
OF THE BEST PRESIDENTS ON
IMMIGRATION, WHICH IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
COMMERCIAL FLIGHTS.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
BORDER PATROL COUNCIL, BRANDON
JUDD, SAID THAT'S BECAUSE THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION HOLDOVERS
ARE STILL RUNNING MAJOR
AGENCIES.
HE JOINS US NOW VIA SKYPE FROM
MONTANA.
ALSO JOINING US FROM SAN DIEGO
IS IMMIGRATION ADVOCATE AND
RICKY MARONE IS UP FROM
SAN DIEGO.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
LET'S START WITH YOU BRANDON.
THIS IS THE PROGRAM WHICH TOOK
PLACE AND BEGAN UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IT WAS RECENTLY PASSED IN 2008
AND EVENTUALLY IT WAS CHILD
IMMEDIATELY DEPORT MINORS BACK
TO NONCONTIGUOUS COUNTRIES.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT, HOWEVER,
>> IT IS, AND IT ACTUALLY
EXPANDED FROM 2008 TO RELEASING
ANYBODY THAT CLAIMED A CREDIBLE
FEAR AND SAID THEY DIDN'T WANT
TO GO BACK TO THEIR COUNTRY.
WE WERE RELEASING ALL IMMIGRANTS
THAT CAME ACROSS A LEAK
ILLEGALLY.
>> Laura: WHY IS THIS THE WAY
TO ENFORCE AMERICAN IMMIGRATION
ON THE BOOKS?
TO ME IT SEEMS LIKE A MAGNET.
IF YOU TELL PEOPLE AND GET
ACROSS THE BORDER, WE WILL
PROTECT YOU, WE WILL SEND YOU TO
A SPONSOR.
IS HE THERE?
OTHERWISE HE HAS CHANGED.
WE WILL SEND YOU ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY TO VARIOUS LOCATIONS,
AND YOU WILL BE ABLE TO STAY.
THERE HE IS.
WHAT OF THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL THAT'S NOT TRUE.
BEEN LESS MIGRANT CROSSING THE
BORDER, ESPECIALLY FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA.
IT'S A VERY, VERY DIFFICULT TO
GET A SILENT, VERY DIFFICULT.
WANT THE BORDER PATROL UNION, IF
THAT WERE HAPPENING, THE BORDER
PATROL UNION IS GREATLY
RESPONSIBLE BECAUSE THEY ARE
SUPPORTING THAT CONCEPT TO
SMUGGLERS.
>> Laura: I'M CONFUSED THOUGH.
>> THEY STARTED THIS PROGRAM AND
THE PEOPLE THAT DO HAVE CREDIBLE
FEAR AND YOU HAVE A FAMILY
MEMBER, MANY OF THEM ARE ALLOWED
TO TO THAT FAMILY MEMBER AND
STAY THERE UNTIL THEY GO    GO T
STAY THERE UNTIL THEY GO    GO O
TIME.
NO.
LET'S PLAY TAG HERE.
>> WITH THESE CASES ON MANY
OCCASIONS --
DEPORTED SHOW UP AT THEIR
HEARINGS?
YOU KNOW SO MUCH.
>> ABOUT 35%.
>> Laura: BRANDON.
THEY NEVER SHOW UP HERE THAT'S A
BRANDON, GO AHEAD.
>> WHO'S THE LIAR HERE?
>> Laura: WHY ARE YOU ON WITH
US IF YOU'RE GOING TO CALL IS A
LIAR?
WHY ARE YOU ON A NETWORK THAT IS
FILLED WITH LIARS?
HOLD ON A SECOND, BRANDON.
HENRIQUE, ONE QUESTION.
BRANDON, I ASKED YOU A SIMPLE
QUESTION AND YOU WENT TO ANOTHER
POINT, WHICH IS CUTE, BUT IT
REALLY DOESN'T WORK ON THE SHOW.
I ASKED YOU A QUESTION.
HOW IS IT ENFORCING U.S. LAW TO
SAY, IF YOU CROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY, YOU WILL COME UP MOST
KNOWN FELON, YOU WILL BE RELEASD
AFTER A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME TO
A SPONSOR, AND YOU WILL BE FLOWN
VIA COMMERCIAL AIRLINE WITH AN
HHS ESCORT TO YOUR LOCATION OF
CHOICE.
MY QUESTION WAS, HOW IS THAT
WILL GET A SHOT.
>> IT'S NOT HAPPENING.
IT'S VERY RARE EXCEPTIONS THAT
THAT TAKE PLACE.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU KNOW THE
40% DROP IN UNDOCUMENTED
INCREASE IN SOUTHWEST BORDER
FAMILY UNIT APPREHENSIONS FROM
APRIL 2017 TO DECEMBER 2017.
WE HAVE 1,226 FAMILY UNITS
CROSSING IN APRIL.
DECEMBER WE HAD 8,121, JUST IN
ONE MONTH.
ONE MONTH 8,121 FAMILIES
CROSSING THE BORDER IN
ANTICIPATION, UNDOUBTEDLY, OF
AMNESTY.
BRANDON, I DO NOT GIVE YOU
ENOUGH TIME HERE.
IF ENRIQUE MIGHT LET YOU SPEAK,
FIVE SECONDS.
>> LAURA, I CAN PERSONALLY TELL
YOU I DID A SHIP OR PATROLLING
THE BORDERS TODAY.
I CAN TELL YOU WE LET GO OF
NEARLY ALL INDIVIDUALS CROSSING.
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, BUT YOU
STILL HAVE THOSE OBAMA HOLDOVERS
THAT ARE FORCING US TO PROCESS
THE ILLEGAL ALIENS THAT WE CATCH
AND SET THEM UP SO THEY CAN THEN
CHANGE BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TOUGH ON
A SOUND BITE FROM A FLIGHT
ATTENDANT WHO CALLED INTO MY
RADIO SHOW TODAY.
LET'S LISTEN REALLY QUICK.
>> THERE WERE FOUR OF THEM.
CHILDREN.
THEY ALL HAVE A BRAND-NEW CLOSE,
ONE BAG OF ALL BRAND-NEW
BELONGINGS.
NO I.D. WHATSOEVER.
>> Laura: THEY HAD AN ESCORT
WITH THEM AND SHE DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE THEY ENDED UP ULTIMATELY,
BUT THIS HAPPENS TIME AND TIME
TALKING ABOUT.
ENRIQUE CRITICALLY RESPONSE.
>> WANTED TO ASK CHRIS HARRIS.
HE'S THE BORDER CONTROL FREAK
OUT.
STAY SHOT AND KILLED A MIGRANT.
THIS IS WHAT'S REALLY TAKING
PLACE ALONG THE BORDER.
THEY ARE TAKING EXCEPTIONAL
CASES AND TRYING TO MAKE IT
SOUND LIKE IT'S HAPPENING ALL
THE TIME.
THESE ARE RARE EXCEPTIONS, THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE FORCED TO LEAVE,
MUCH OF IT COULD BE U.S.
INTERFERENCE.
THE U.S. SHOULD BE MUCH MORE
WELCOMING.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN IN THE TOP 20
COUNTRIES.
>> Laura: YOU JUST DON'T WANT
TO BORDER AT ALL?
>> I DO WANT A BOARD.
WHAT IS THAT.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT I WANT.
I WANT AN INTELLIGENT BORDER.
>> Laura: NOT JUST A CLICHE.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IF YOU CANNOT ANSWER THE